[Music]
if someone asked you who their richest
people in history were who would your
name
perhaps a billionaire banker or
corporate mogul like Bill Gates or john
d rockefeller how about African King
Musa Keita the first ruling the Mali
Empire in the 14th century CE II Mansa
Musa or the King of Kings amassed a
fortune that possibly made him one of
the wealthiest people who ever lived
but his vast wealth was only one piece
of his rich legacy when Mansa Musa came
to power in 1312 much of Europe was
wracked by famine and civil wars but
many African kingdoms and the Islamic
world were flourishing and Mansa Musa
played a great role in bringing the
fruits of this flourishing to his own
realm by strategically annexing the city
of Timbuktu and re-establishing power
over the city of Gaul he gained control
over important trade routes between the
Mediterranean and the west african coast
continuing a period of expansion which
dramatically increased Mali size the
territory of the Mali Empire was rich in
natural resources such as gold and salt
the world first witnessed the extent of
Mansa Musa's wealth in 1324 when he took
his pilgrimage to Mecca not one to
travel on a budget
he brought a caravan stretching as far
as the eye could see accounts of this
journey are mostly based on an oral
testimony and differing written records
so it's difficult to determine the exact
details but what most agree on is the
extravagant scale of the excursion
chroniclers describe an entourage of
tens of thousands of soldiers civilians
and sleeves 500 heralds bearing gold
staffs and dressed in fine silks and
many camels and horses bearing an
abundance of gold bars
stopping in cities such as Cairo Mansa
Musa is said to have spent massive
quantities of gold giving to the poor
buying souvenirs and even having mosques
built along the way in fact his spending
may have destabilized the regional
economy causing mass inflation
this journey reportedly took over a year
and by the time Mansa Musa returned
tales of his amazing wealth had spread
to the ports of the Mediterranean Mali
and its King were elevated to near
legendary status cemented by their
inclusion on the 1375 Catalan Atlas one
of the most important world maps of
medieval Europe it depicted the king
holding a scepter and a gleaming gold
nugget Mansa Musa had literally put his
empire and himself on the map but
material riches weren't the Kings only
concern as a devout Muslim
he took a particular interest in
Timbuktu already a center of religion
and learning prior to its annexation
upon returning from his pilgrimage he
had the great jingoro Barre mosque built
there with the help of an Andalusian
architect he also established a major
university further elevating the city's
reputation and attracting scholars and
students from all over the Islamic world
under Mansa Musa the Empire became
urbanized with schools and mosques in
hundreds of densely populated towns the
King's rich legacy persisted for
generations and to this day there are
mausoleums libraries and mosques that
stand as a testament to this Golden Age
of Mali's history
you
[Music]